Is there any problem with doing foot bath since I have a pacemaker and do the foot baths affect your electrolytes?
My potassium tends to be low.
If you're doing a foot bath every day, could it cause you to lose more electrolytes?
Maybe a little.
Would you have to be careful with if you have low potassium and you have low electrolytes and you have trouble keeping minerals in your body would be so much more than foot baths?
I don't think you're really going to lose a lot.
If you're using an ionic foot bath which is a little bit different than the true right foot bath, you'd have a greater chance of losing minerals using that.
But still, I don't think you're losing a lot of minerals with a foot bath.
If you don't, I would recommend doing foot baths every day anyhow.
But I think you'd be safe doing foot baths.